le 26 février à la défense pas très loin
d'ici puisque nous offre la pelouse de
bagatelle jacques chirac rencontrait
6000 jeunes pour les écouter et
dialoguer avec eux depuis le début de la
campagne sans humilier à lui avoir écrit
pour lui faire part de leurs
préoccupations
ce soir nous avons choisi le cap de ce
midi à bagatelle où chirac rend compte à
nouveau des milliers de jeunes pour
parler leurs préoccupations je vous
propose de commencer par le thème de
l'économie et plus particulièrement par
les problèmes si important de la
recherche et d'information
l'économie européenne a longtemps dominé
le monde
aujourd'hui c'est le comprennent
les nouveaux pays industrialisés nous
inondent de produits à haute technologie
et à bas prix il nous amène à nous
interroger sur notre avenir économique
l'un des défis de l'an 2000 elle l'a
quelles sont les solutions en voici deux
tout à fait essentiel
d'abord la recherche
elle est vitale pour nos entreprises et
notre emploi
e
ensuite la formation et l'apprentissage
ils sont d'autant plus nécessaire qu'il
faudra changer plusieurs fois de métier
dans une vie
mais pour ce million d'apprentis en
arrête pas il n'y en a que deux cent
quinze mille en france
monsieur le premier ministre ma question
concerne le problème de formation j'ai
créé une entreprise voilà huit ans
aujourd'hui nous représentons la
première chaîne d'opticiens franchisés
en europe nous pourrions faire beaucoup
plus si nous avions à notre disposition
des opticiens diplômés en plus grande
quantité j'apporte le marché européen je
m'installe dans les principales villes
d'europe
j'aimerais savoir quel est ce que vous
envisagez vis-à-vis des problèmes de
l'information et de la formation des
jeunes pour les diriger vers les emplois
que nous demandons nous et qui
malheureusement ne répondent pas il est
évident ans nous avons dans ce domaine
du retard et que notre système
d'éducation est resté trop longtemps
enfermés dans une sorte de ghetto il
faut d'abord prévoir et cela ne peut
être fait qu'en liaison avec les forces
vives de la nation les emplois qui
seront disponibles dans les années
suivantes et ensuite il faut créer les
filières de formation à la foi dans
notre système d'éducation et de notre
système de formation professionnelle
pour remplir ces emplois donc c'est la
réforme ne peut pas rentrer ici dans le
détail de notre système d'éducation et
de notre système de formation qui est en
cause avec comme clé de voûte si j'ose
dire lité 9 pour nous aujourd'hui d'une
articulation étroite entre le monde
économique la vie économique les
entreprises et le système d'éducation et
de formation
jacques chirac l'économie c'est aussi
les hommes leur vie de tous les jours
nicolas et moi nous avons
choisit d'abord de rappeler les
résultats que vous avez obtenus en
faveur de l'emploi des jeunes en 1985 26
% des demandeurs d'emploi étaient des
jeunes
entre 86 et 87 1 millions 700 mille
jeunes accueillis en entreprise
un truc sur trois trouvent un vrai
emploi
1987 année record pour la création
d'entreprise
aujourd'hui de nombreux français de trop
nombreux français vivent un drame
quotidien ils n'ont plus rien pour vivre
cela ne pose-t-il pas des mesures
d'urgence que des mesures d'urgence
soient prises
des mesures d'urgence sont prises
et le problème il faut le savoir le plus
difficile n'est pas tellement de venir
en aide nous avons naturellement les
moyens et d'ailleurs les procédures et
les réglementations qui permettent de
venir en aide dans la plupart des cas
mais le drame c'est que l'on a créé une
situation où des hommes et des femmes se
sentent exclus au point de ne pas
vouloir se manifester
notamment auprès de l'administration et
donc ce qui est important c'est d'abord
de les détecter se caractérise et avec
un peu de coeur en le personnalisant
leur situation et à partir de là de leur
donner les moyens par une formation par
un effort personnel de réinsertion dans
la société par un travail utile modeste
de gagner le revenu que par ailleurs il
faut le rassurer mais de façon à ce que
lorsque l'intéressé rentrer chez lui ils
ne disent pas simplement j'ai reçu mon
assistance au guichet de
l'administration
car ça ce n'est pas convenable ni signe
d'un homme et qu'il tige au contraire
j'ai fait un effort et cet effort
comporte une juste rétribution
c'est cela une véritable politique de
solidarité nationale
dans leur immense majorité sont très
préoccupés par le devenir du tiers-monde
il souhaite une france qui soit dans le
monde généreuse porteuse de fraternité
souvenez vous c'était le 20 juin pas
très loin d'ici à la défense dans le
cadre de la journée de la performance
vous assistiez à la remise à une équipe
de jeunes français d'un chèque de 50
mille francs ce chèque ils l'ont reçue
pour l'originalité est aussi et surtout
pour la générosité de leurs projets du
projet qu'il vous avait présenté il
partait au cours de l'été 87 au caire
donné leur concours à la construction
d'une léproserie et il nous propose ce
soir un document exceptionnel que l'on
commence à voir qui est réalisé à partir
de photos qu'ils ont prises eux mêmes et
dont nous avons sélectionné les
meilleurs
aujourd'hui ils ont accepté de venir
parce que ils méritent d'être félicités
en juillet et en août dernier ils sont
effectivement partis ils honte
effectivement réussi la léproserie au
caire fonctionne j'accueille eric de
neuville et bernard le gartner
je voudrais simplement félicité eric et
bernard
qui ont apporté leur contribution à ce
que j'appelais tout à l'heure
l'obligation du coeur pour ceux qui
souffrent et notamment dans ce continent
merveilleux et si proche de nous qu'est
l'afrique mais où hélas
se creuse de plus en plus entre eux et
nous le procès de la différence
ces pays africains s'enferment dans le
malheur et la misère et nous ne faisons
pas que ce que nous devons pour eux pas
tout ce que nous devons aux certes la
france fait beaucoup de choses si par
tête d'habitant les américains et les
japonais donner autant que les français
qui sont les premiers dans le monde pour
ce qui concerne l'aide de coopération il
y aurait pratiquement plus aucun
problème pour ce qui concerne le
développement dans toute la région
africaine mais hélas ce n'est pas le cas
et nous sommes entourés de gens qui dans
les grands pays industrialisés sont
encore marqués par un très profond
égoïsme alors en dehors des aides de
l'état il ya aussi les aides tessin et
des autres les aides en particulier pour
tout ce qui concerne le développement
mais aussi la lutte contre la faim et la
lutte contre la misère et la maladie est
ce qu'on paie eric et bernard en
participant à la construction de cette
les procès au caire est un de ces gestes
qui font honneur à notre jeunesse mais
vous savez il est de nombreuses
associations
étaient notamment ou impulsée notamment
par le ministère de la coopération et
qui pourrait vous permettre à vous aussi
de prendre des initiatives de cette
nature et de participer pour un temps
par exemple a été ici ou là dans un pays
africain qui en a besoin a été au
développement ou à la lutte contre la
faim et la misère il nous appartient
enfin mais ça c'est du ressort des états
de faire en sorte que ces pays de plus
ne perdent pas totalement l'espoir comme
c'est aujourd'hui le cas avec
l'endettement qui se referme par un
haussement autour d'eux et que nous
devons impérativement régler mais ça
c'est une affaire c'est une autre
histoire c'est une affaire des
gouvernements et la france aaa honneur
d'être le pays qui de ce point de vue
est le seul à faire des propositions
concrètes et généreuse pour sortir ces
pays de cet endettement qui les prive en
réalité de l'espoir et les privant de
l'espoir les pires un peu de la vie
c'est le dernier sujet maintenant et la
france que nous allons voir c'est celle
qui correspond à ce que vous êtes à ce
que vous voulez faire pour elle c'est la
france olympique
l'organisation des jeux de l'avant
cinquième olympiade
1992 jeux d'hiver à la ville de
hal belleville
je ne finis dans les branches riche et
varié voilà mais le savoyard on les jeux
olympiques en 92
je suis très heureux de dire
qu'à ce moment là quand nous avons gagné
à présent une bataille de six années
mené avec jean claude killy et toute
notre équipe
nous avions eu à chaque jour et
notamment dans les derniers jours qu'ils
étaient les plus importants jacques
chirac à côté de nous
en 1968 au mois de février j'avais 17
ans j'étais déjà un militant gaulliste
au sein de l'ue jp
je me trouvais à grenon pour la ville
d'alain carignon quitter lui aussi à
l'egypte et
et l'une de mes toutes premières
émotions deux jeunes hommes politiques
sera été d'entendre le général de gaulle
ouvrir les jeux olympiques de grenoble
eh bien chers amis
parce qu'il s'agit des jeux olympiques
parce qu'il s'agit de la france
parce qu'il s'agit de cet événement
fantastique tel que je viens de le
décrire je n'imagine pas une seule
seconde que le 1er février 92 ce soit
quelqu'un d'autre que jacques chirac qui
ouvre les jeux olympiques d'albertville
et